semblait indispensable d'entendre les
fédérations d'établissements alors il
est vrai que les problématiques
elles peuvent être très différentes
selon la nature des établissements
certaines sont propres à l'hôpital
public qui représentent la part
dominante de l'activité hospitalière
mais nous avons souhaité normand cette
position commune on a l'habitude en
général vous entendre en commun c'est
vrai que là on aurait pu dire mais c'est
hôpital public
nous avons souhaité vous entendre
ensemble car une partie des difficultés
actuelles touche au fonctionnement
global de notre système de santé qu'il
s'agisse de l'accès aux soins mais aussi
des modalités de prise en charge des
soins non programmés
notre préoccupation c'est bien entendu
de faciliter l'accès du patient aux
soins les plus adaptées que justifie sa
situation qu'ils relèvent de structures
publiques ou privées hospitalière ou non
nous souhaiterions que chacun d'entre
vous dans une présentation introductive
que je vous demanderais brève formule
ses principaux constats sur la situation
actuelle du système hospitalier et les
facteurs de tension qui a fait que la
prise en charge des patients et le
fonctionnement des établissements
nous pourrons ensuite abordé plus
particulièrement les aspects liés à
l'organisation la gouvernance des
établissements leur relation et la
tutelle leur situation financière leur
mode de financement aux enjeux de
recrutement et de fidélisation des
personnels à la structuration
territoriale de l'offre hospitalière
publique et privée et son articulation
avec la médecine de ville et bien
entendu il sera possible de nous
adresser des contributions écrites un
point important qui a été soulevé aussi
lors de l'édition précédente était celui
de la formation le formation que les
différents intervenants le souhaitait
voir élargi élargie au delà de du simple
hôpital public voilà alors qu'ils
commencent c'est valletoux bien
peut-être la parole à monsieur monsieur
van houtte pas du tout en suivant sa
chance moi vous avez entre 5 à 7 minutes
pour vous exprimer avec nouveaux
appareils interrogé sur des questions
sur des questions aussi simple très bien
monsieur le vice président madame
rapporteur merci de cette occasion de
nous inviter à cette occasion pour
effectivement évoqué la situation et
l'avenir de l'hôpital et du système de
santé puisque je veux saluer commencé en
saluant effectivement l'intitulé de
cette commission denquête qui est
satisfaisant de notre point de vue parce
que effectivement elle
elle a pour objectif visiblement de
s'intéresser à l'ensemble du système de
santé de ces défauts de ses
insuffisances de ces dysfonctionnements
et pas simplement l'hôpital dans ses
quatre murs
les deux sujets étant intimement liés la
fédération hospitalière de france en une
seule phrase
c'est représentent les 1100 hôpitaux
français les 3800 établissements de
médico-sociaux aussi donc c'est toute
l'offre de santé publique
sanitaire et médico social qui réunit
dans notre dans notre d'un autre
fédération
rapidement pour démarrer sur les
constats et la situation actuelle l'a
bien montré l'hôpital public est dans
une situation paradoxale à la fois la
crise a rappelé sa force incroyable sa
souplesse et aussi sa réactivité au
service de la population sa capacité de
mobilisation et on le voit l'occasion de
la cinquième vague
rappeler d'une phrase que l'hôpital
reste un lieu d'excellence de recherche
d'innovation de première médicale
important pour notre pays et qui est
aussi un lieu très peu de recrues tease
et je veux le dire parce que parfois on
n'en voulons lit les chiffres qui sont
pas toujours les bons contrairement à ce
qu'on entend se veut dire l'hôpital
effectivement compte 10% personnel
administratif pavin pas 30 pas 40 pas je
sais pas combien 10% personnel
administratif environ soit un peu moins
que d'ailleurs dans le secteur privé ou
dans d'autres secteurs et ce chiffre
inclut même selon les statistiques
officielles les secrétaires médicales
qui n'ont de qui ne sont absolument pas
être assimilés à des bureaucrates
rappeler aussi que l'hôpital
normalement grc 50 % 57 % des séjours
d'hospitalisation habituellement aux
reprises
or on a vu pendant la crise que c'est
l'hôpital qui a pris en charge 80 3% en
moyenne des patients qu'aux vide qui ont
dû être hospitalisés en établissement et
ça partout en france enfin et je veux le
dire aussi d'une phrase c'est l'hôpital
qui a montré aussi quasiment du jour au
lendemain c'était une conférence lors
visio un dimanche soir et une campagne
signée une campagne de vaccination qui
démarrait dès le lundi matin qui a aussi
montré sa capacité à
rapidement déployés et être support d'un
déploiement la campagne de vaccination
mais ça n'est pas le sujet c'était juste
pour évoquer la formidable capacité
d'adaptation de nos de nos
établissements de l'autre
bien sûr cet engagement sans compter est
venu aussi accentuer les fragilités bien
connus de cet hôpital fragilité connu
depuis des années elles sont de trois
heures principal pour faire vite et
synthétique ce sont d'abord des
fragilités humaines il faut rappeler que
l'hôpital a abordé la crise avec 30% de
postes de praticiens hospitaliers
vacants il faut rappeler que les
tensions sur les recrutements toucher
aussi les pauses infirmiers infirmières
les postes d'aides-soignants bref qu à
tous les étages de l'hôpital les
tensions sur les effectifs étaient déjà
le quotidien des établissements bien
avoir la crise la deuxième hors de l'eau
les deuxièmes fragilité ses fragilités
aurait d'ordre économique
l'investissement à l'hôpital public est
au plus bas depuis 20 ans 80% des
hôpitaux investissement de 3 % leur
chiffre d'affaires ce qui est largement
insuffisant pour renouveler leurs
équipements courants alors le ségur
apporte une réponse à cet état de fait
mais il faut toujours rappeler que les
économies demandées aux établissements
publics ont représenté près de 10
milliards d'euros ces quinze dernières
années pour mesurer effectivement l'état
de financement de nos établissements et
puis le 3 les troisièmes fragilité c'est
les fragilités qui sont liées à
l'organisation défaillante du système de
santé et effectivement qu'à l'hôpital
et de notre point de vue joue souvent le
rôle de jaillir de variable d'ajustement
de tension de défauts d'angle mort du
système de santé et notamment concernant
la permanence des soins
sur ce sujet d'un système de santé qui
dans les dysfonctionnements pèsent sur
l'hôpital et et sur les mots de ce
système de santé le première le premier
sujet c'est de rappeler la crise
profonde de la médecine de ville on
parle beaucoup de la crise de l'hôpital
parce que c'est sans doute effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit madame la
rapporteure le centre le coeur du
système de santé c'est aussi peut être
la partie la plus visible mais voilà la
médecine de santé traverse une crise qui
est profonde qui est d'abord une crise
des vocations si on peut dire ça comme
ça entre 2010 et 2025 la france aura
compté 13 % de médecins généralistes en
moins c'est-à-dire douze mille médecins
en moins sur notre territoire et
évidemment il n'y a pas besoin de grands
discours pour savoir que le sujet des
déserts médicaux c'est le quotidien des
français et qu'ils soient ruraux ou
urbains
l'ordre des médecins a publié beaucoup
d'analysés dessus les deux de
statistiques sur le sujet de
perspectives aussi
qu'ils doivent être prises en compte
lorsqu'on regarde l'ensemble du système
de santé
au delà du nombre il ya des territoires
plus avantagés que d'autres et plus
avantagé au lit que d'autres les écarts
sont spectaculaires dans certaines
spécialités l'écart pour cent mille
habitants en termes de médecin
psychiatre je veux juste citer ce
chiffre varie de 1 à 40 environ par
territoire est en jeu j'englobe dans les
dents les médecins psychiatres aussi
bien les libéraux que les médecins
salariés ce qui prouve que je fasse ce
qui tend à démontrer une autre chose que
l'on sait mais qu'il faut toujours
rappeler que ces déséquilibres
évidemment entre territoires mettre à
mal le principe d'égalité devant le
système de santé de nos concitoyens
soumis à ces à ces écarts qui sont
importants le deuxième des fois notre
système de santé c'est un défaut de
prévention la population vieillit
augmente les maladies chroniques
prennent une place qui est toujours plus
grande or notre système de santé qu'il
fait part hier de place à la médecine
scolaire la médecine du travail et ne
rétribuent pas la prévention échoue trop
souvent à prévenir des hospitalisations
évitables le troisième aspect c'est
l'insuffisance historique du nombre de
professionnels formés sujet de la
formation vous avez rapidement évoqué
médecins comme comme paramédicaux et le
quatrième et dernier aspect c'est celui
la défaillance de régulation d'un
système de santé dans les territoires on
a besoin de plus d'équité entre tous les
acteurs et que chacun prenne sa part
pour le coc vide c'est la question qui
est posée ces jours-ci aussi bien du
côté du gouvernement que des
hospitaliers avec la permanence de soins
et le poids des déprogrammations sur les
différents établissements
s'il ya eu il ya eu une union sanitaire
qui s'est créé au moment de la première
vague tout cela s'est largement déliter
et comme on est la cinquième vague
aujourd'hui il ya des situations
effectivement qui tendent à rappeler que
l'hôpital ne peut pas seul à faire face
à la
poussez nouvelles de l'épidémie et que
tous les acteurs du système de santé
doivent prendre leur part à l'effort et
on le voit dans les chiffres d'activité
aujourd'hui notamment des activités
chirurgicales que connaissent les
différents secteurs voilà on a besoin
d'un arbitre on a besoin d'un arbitre
qui soit qui soit l'état qui soit l'état
à travers l'assurance maladie qui soit
l'état régulateur et qui soit un
régulateur qui ne pèse pas que sur la
partie publique de l'offre de soins mais
qui sont arrivés la terre qui pèse sur
l'ensemble du système de santé puisque
il ya une règle que l'on connaît tous ce
système de santé il est financé par une
banque unique qui s'appelle l'assurance
maladie qui à partir de là il faut sans
doute et peut-être cette commission en
est l'occasion reposer la question des
droits et des devoirs de chaque acteur à
partir du moment où le système de
financement et la même voilà donc
repenser l'organisation du système de la
l'organisation la santé dans les
territoires repenser la question du
financement et notamment envers là pour
valoriser la recherche pour valoriser
l'investissement pour valoriser les bans
pertinentes et lutter contre ces 30 % de
dépenses non pertinentes en système de
santé chiffrent déjà dire qu'il revient
mais auquel pour l'instant on ne
s'attaque pas revoir les problématiques
de carrière et de métier à l'hôpital il
manque 25 mille personnes à l'hôpital
non pas pour être rajouté des effectifs
là où rajouter des effectifs en plus
pardon mais simplement pour jédir entre
guillemets boucher les trous c'est à
dire satisfaire aux emplois et aux
postes qu'ils sont non pourvus enfin
dernier sujet et je m'arrêterai là il ya
la question derrière tout ça du grand
âge et la prévention qui doivent être
des priorités affirmées sur le grand âge
vous savez quel point cette réforme a
été de deux quinquennats en quinquennat
repoussé et reporté mais pourtant elle
présente enfin le sujet de la dépendance
présente des défis immenses qui aussi
près sur le système de santé merci
beaucoup
je vous remercie monsieur le président
nous allons passer la parole à à
monsieur le président augure bixi je
veux bien merci merci
merci merci beaucoup pour cette
tradition est donc je souhaite saluer
l'initiative puisque que le bienvenu de
cette commission denquête et la rapidité
avec laquelle vous avez exprimé le
souhaite d'auditionner toutes les
fédérations hospitalières dans un sens
unique je salue aussi l'esprit qui
gouvernent son objet à savoir la volonté
d'une réflexion globale sur
l'articulation des acteurs de santé
entre eux la présence aujourd'hui de
représentants des quatre fédérations
illustre cette volonté de trouver
ensemble les solutions pour faire
progresser notre système de santé au
service de tous et je ne veux pas
gaspiller le temps précieux que nous
avons ensemble pour rappeler les
constats sur lesquels à quelques nuances
près avec mon homologue de l'era chef
nous convergeons tous
mais naturellement il est impossible
s'exprimer en apesanteur sur une crise
sanitaire qui n'est hélas pas derrière
nous la pandémie ont en effet démontré
d'une manière impérieuse que sans
coopération et les twins à lui le privé
a pris toute sa part
en prenant en charge 25 % des patients
en réanimation même si les patients
qu'aux vide ne représente que 3% des
patients pris en charge au quotidien
cela suppose que l'équité devienne une
réalité effective autour notamment de
deux principaux clé de principes clés
pardon un même patient un même soin à
même tarif alors que subsistent des
écarts tarifaires non justifiée entre le
public et le privé 20% mc aux 100 à 300%
en soins de suite et psychiatrie autre
principe clé une revalorisation
salariale identique pour le
professionnel du privé qui soigne les
mêmes malades ce que les ségur c'est sur
deux n'a pas fait il nous faut
collectivement dépasser les
cloisonnements et rigidité cela impose à
notre sens trois changements majeurs de
paradigme le premier
modifiant la vision de l'action
territoriale afin qu'elle associe
l'ensemble des acteurs de santé autour
de mission partagée au sein d'un service
public hospitalier
profondément refonder pendant la crise
sanitaire sous l'égide de la régulation
équilibrée des ars des dynamique
vertueuse de coopération et émerger
qu'il faut sanctuariser
à chaque jour de bataille contre le
virus la conception actuelle le service
public hospitalier qui exclut le privé
devient encore plus obsolète et contre
productive je ne parle je ne partage pas
l'idée qu'une situation exceptionnelle
ne puisse pas être dupliqué dans un
contexte plus classique ce serait
désespérant et signifierait que nous
tirons pas les leçons
coopérons les coopérations pérenniser
donc sph refonder et ars recentrer sur
leur mission ce qui suppose le délester
de la gestion de l'hôpital pluie
faisant cela dès à présent expérimentons
sur un ou deux territoires et on
constatera que cette démocratie
territoriale de santé vivante et la
seule bonne manière de répondre aux
attentes des patients aux enjeux d'accès
aux soins deuxièmement faisons évoluer
notre rapport la confiance et à la
responsabilité
alors que notre gouvernance est encore
si corsetée descendante cloisonnée entre
statut et deux protocoles signés entre
l'état et les fédérations hospitalières
plus réalité et plus récemment réforme
des financements amorce une nouvelle
forme de dialogue plus mature entre
l'état et les acteurs de santé ce
dialogue est fondée sur la
contractualisation autour d'un gain
réciproque et l'évaluation a posteriori
du respect des engagements
mais c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt si
nous voulons mettre un terme aux maux
qui rongent le système il est nécessaire
d' impulser une gouvernance plus moderne
basée sur le partage la transparence de
données et une vision prospective des
enjeux visibilité et rim avec sérénité
quand de profession reçoit en pleine
cinquième vague alors même que tout ça
bisman sont mobilisés une demande
d'économies de l'ordre de 100 millions
d'euros lié à la non restitution de la
mise en réserve présidentielle et alors
même que 20 milliards 20 milliards ont
été attribués ou vont être attribués au
seul au but au public le découragement
vous saisit dans un contexte de crise le
sens général l'intérêt général reprend
immédiatement dessus
mais clairement la donne doit changer je
sais vous êtes nombreux ici à porter la
pérennité de l'homme de l'andam au nom
de cette visibilité qui le sort le sort
de la confiance
enfin apprenons à oeuvrer ensemble sur
les sujets qui nous rassemble sur le
sujet capital de la pénurie
professionnels de santé il est navrant
de voir que chacun se renvoie la balle
pour savoir qui est le plus attractif et
qui pique les soignants à l'autre la
situation est infiniment plus complexe
remédier aux pénuries amplifié
considérablement à l'effort de formation
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers de
santé proposer des évolutions de
carrière qu'ils fassent fi des statuts
des lieux d'exercice c'est un sujet de
société qui nous embarque tous
aujourd'hui 10% des effectifs parler ni
caution non pourvus et certaines
activités sont impactés soit j'ai fait
trois ans que la fhp a l'air sur ce
point les choses vont pas assez vite
pour se dépasser notre système de santé
a aussi besoin d'évoluer en diversifiant
les profils et les viviers de
recrutement des personnels qui composent
sa gouvernance cela profitera à tous y
compris pour relever les défis colossaux
tels que la santé numérique nous
attendent tous ces dépassements sont en
outre portées au jaune aujourd'hui
l'heure est à l'union contre le virus et
le privé est pleinement et
inconditionnellement mobiliser notre
inquiétude est grande de voir le
principe d'équité qui avait prévalu ces
derniers mois se déliter les acteurs
rudement éprouvées cela a été dit
rappeler ont besoin de considération et
l'avenir du système passe par la
reconnaissance de tous mais je veux
croire en cette intelligence collective
merci monsieur nous allons passer la
parole à madame de soldes s'il vous
plaît oui merci beaucoup mais ce vice
président je vous en prie
madame le rapporteur
c'est intéressant de voir la
confrontation un peu d'aidé des idées
autour de la fhf et de la fhp je ne sais
pas si on va faire synthèse mais le fait
est que je me retrouve dans une partie
des propos de frédéric valletoux dont
une partie des propos de de la mine
garbino merci vraiment pour cette pour
pour cette initiative alors oui les
hôpitaux sont sous tension alors ma
quand je dis hôpital je suis pas sûr
qu'on mette tous la même chose sous les
sous les mots hôpital c'est pas
forcément hôpital public donc hôpital
ça correspond à une dimension d'un
établissement de santé qui assurent des
missions de
médecine de chirurgie et d'obstétrique
donc
quelquefois je me dis que les mots
eux-mêmes porte porte confusion et c'est
vrai que si les hôpitaux sont sous
tension comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer je rejoins frédéric
valletoux
laquelle hospital au centrisme et dans
le système de santé et un risque est un
facteur
de risques y compris pour l'hôpital
auger pablo spillane centriste est
voulue par pas par l'hôpital et c'est
l'ensemble du système de santé qui a
conduit à qui a conduit à cela et qui
finalement créé un facteur de risque et
donc on à cercle vicieux qui s'est un
peu installés dont on peut se poser la
question de savoir comment on en sort je
dois dire que à la fédération nous
étions assez favorable à ma santé 2022
tels que ça avait été pensé au démarrage
qui était quand même une réflexion sur
comment on répond sur les territoires
aux besoins des patients en essayant de
sortir des des dynamiques de
d'établissement et de et de statut donc
oui il ya cette question de notre fidèle
centrisme oui il ya les tensions rh donc
nous avons des problématiques de
fidélisation de nos professionnels nous
avons des problématiques de recrutement
nous avons certes des professionnels qui
se forment mais qui vont pas forcément
au bout des formations et donc on se
retrouve au final avec une vraie
difficulté à avoir des professionnels
compétents qualifiés en nombre suffisant
pour pouvoir répondre aux besoins des
des patients et puis dans dans
l'explication aujourd'hui détention peut
être une explication qui est plus porté
par notre fédération qui représente le
privé solidaire donc il ya pour vocation
assumer des missions de service public
c'est l'idée que on a hélas mais le
garde il a dit d'une certaine façon on a
une vision du ministère qui est qui
résonne beaucoup par statut et non pas
par la réponse apportée est quand même
on pourrait se dire que la bonne manière
de réfléchir c'est de se dire mais qui
apporte la réponse et comme en fonction
de la réponse apportée on peut envisager
effectivement la rémunération et les
logiques de de tarification et et à cela
je rajouterais ce que les autres ont dit
c'est quelque chose qui est très
administrée et donc qui est décent
beaucoup un dut
du national est sans doute avec une
insuffisance de la logique de contrat
c'est à dire que la logique de contrat
on a beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui à ce
qu'elle fasse vraiment ce qu'elle fasse
vraiment sens alors je ne vais pas
parler longtemps de l'aféas vous pouvez
regarder sur le site tout ce que vous
voulez savoir sur la
voulais juste dire que dans
dans le fonctionnement du système de
santé et en temps de crise quand on
considère qu'on a une certaine
performance du modèle voilà donc on veut
juste de dire que l'on on en est on en
est persuadé d'abord parce que la
gouvernance c'est une gouvernance qui
est basé sur l'engagement de personnes
qualifiées qui est une gestion
désintéressée
pour lesquels donc on avec lequel on
remplit donc des missions de service
public sans reste à charge pour
et pour les peaux pour les patients avec
d'ailleurs aussi pas de dépassements
d'honoraires puisque nous n'avons pas
d'activité libérale
dans l'autre dans les établissements de
notre de notre fédération et donc nous
sommes en capacité de porter et les
missions de service public et la
recherche et l'innovation de terrain au
même titre que que les autres et que la
force du modèle c'est le contrat c'est à
dire que dans les logiques de
gouvernance je veux dire il y à un
contre un entre le directeur et son
conseil d'administration
on se met d'accord sur quels sont les
objectifs et s'ils ont des objectifs ne
sont pas atteints ma foi on se sépare il
ya un contre un entre les médecins et
les 10 et les directions d'établissement
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs issus de
directeur d'hôpital ingénieurs ou
médecins peu importe d'où d'où ils
viennent mais il ya cette logique qui
est une logique du contrat et qui est
vraiment réciproque c'est un médecin ne
vient que parce qu'on lui dit qu'il va
pouvoir réaliser tel type d'activité qui
va pouvoir se développer etc mais à l
inverse le directeur attendant qu'il
réponde à cette logique d'activités dont
la logique de contrat ne fait sens et ce
contrat il peut être aussi collectif
avec les équipes d'hier donc je crois
que vraiment là on a un sujet qui tient
et et d'ailleurs qui est un modèle qu'on
retrouve dans d'autres pays européens et
qui est parfois dominant dans d'autres
pays européens comme le com comme le
danemark alors donc peut-être qu'on peut
être un modèle voilà j'ai je le dis très
je le dis très très très très simplement
alors ensuite sur cassure cocooning
quelques que peut-on que peut-on faire
c'est vrai que nous avons une ressentons
nous une difficulté par rapport à
actuellement à la proche al'approche
ministériel donc l'approchent
ministérielle sur tout ce qui est
logique de tarification et de et de
rémunération si je le dis de manière un
peu rapide et donc et donc lapidaire
vous m'en excuserez il faudrait sans
doute un peu plus de nuances en gros il
nous l'est dit vous accuse souple et
vous n'êtes plus rien actif que
l'hôpital public donc vous avez besoin
de moins d'argent ce qui de notre point
de vue un petit côté contre-intuitif
donc et donc on se dit que c'est
peut-être pas de cette manière là qu'il
faut poser pour poser le problème est
sûre ça nous nous avons aussi à des
exemples autour du financement du ségur
de donc des carrières etc on a une
enveloppe de 30 % 30 % inférieur sur le
ségur d'investissement de la même façon
donc on voit bien que nous n'avons pas
l'investissement à la hauteur de ce que
nous de ce que nous représentons et là
je ne vous parle pas de l'hôpital je
pourrais vous dire tout ce qu'on peut
également que constater dans le tout le
secteur médico social et social qui pose
là même la même difficulté alors c'est
quoi et c'est quoi les solutions pour
essayer d'aller d'aller un peu
rapidement moi je rejoins la minganie
sur la question de la confiance dans les
acteurs du territoire je pense quand
même que une des solutions c'est un
prenons un territoire donné aux acteurs
qui sont solides des territoires une
certaine responsabilité populationnelle
de réponse des draps et or vu des
tensions que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
peu importe le statut les uns et les
autres l'idée c'est qu'ils coopèrent et
qui compte trouve la réponse pour les
personnes qui vivent sur le territoire
dopé mais c'est partir du territoire et
donc c'est la peau construction entre
les acteurs du territoire c'est pas
quelque chose qui nous descend de que ça
soit du niveau national ou du niveau ou
du niveau régional donc ça il ya
certainement quelque chose autour de ça
on le sait quand on cherche des effets
leviers les effets leviers on les
retrouve globalement dans le financement
parce que c'est souvent quand même un
moteur pour trouver des
effets et des effets leviers et là alors
qu'est ce que l'on constate d'abord on
constate que aujourd'hui pour lâcher à
pain on a eu un décrochage en termes de
grilles de rémunération par rapport au
secteur public alors que nous assumons
des missions de service public ça c'est
la première chose deuxième chose tout
les revalorisations qui se font
actuellement se font sur non pas dans
les tarifs mais se font en aide à la
contractualisation missions d'intérêt
général etc c'est à dire que privilégie
un statut par rapport à la réponse à la
réponse apportée donc s'agirait c'est le
sait le deuxième élément et puis le le
troisième élément alors honnêtement le
gouvernement l'a commencée c'est la
question de la réforme du financement
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant on
reste sur des réformes de financement
qui sont très établissements centre est
et en fait on a beaucoup de mal à sortir
pour avoir des réponses qu'ils soient
plus des logiques hop de parcours comme
on en parle beaucoup sur des territoires
et donc des logiques de forfaits sur la
manière dont on va rémunérer les acteurs
qui au qui ont permis une réponse de
prévention de courts séjours et
éventuellement d'accompagnement et
d'accompagnement à domicile donc le
modèle financier
ferait bouger la manière dont on répond
ah c'est une nouvelle organisation de
notre système de notre système de santé
mais pour ça il faut mettre quand même
tous les acteurs autour de la table mais
il nous semble qu'il ya un chemin
aujourd'hui est que ce conakry ce qu il
a peut-être permis de de faire bouger
dans les lignes c'est que c'est quand
même unis qu'ont réussi à répondre à la
crise et donc si on est uni pour
répondre à la crise peut-être que dans
le fonctionnement quotidien pour mieux
répondre aux besoins des français on
pourrait également subir
merci madame n'a pas voulu tomber d'un
beau-père simply
je vous remercie beaucoup de m'avoir
proposé de participer à cette audition
avec les autres fédérations avec
lesquels on travaille étroitement
effectivement un certain nombre de
points ont déjà été abordées l'union
comme l'évoquait anne marie sophie deux
soeurs évidemment ça a été fondamental
dans le cas de la crise en particulier
d'ailleurs pour assurer la continuité
des soins en matière de cancérologie
unis cancer représente bien sûr les 18
centres de lutte contre le cancer et on
sait l'importance de se battre pour
éviter les retards de diagnostic ont
tenu des conséquences que cela notamment
interne de surmortalité alors c'est avec
les 112 contre le cancer ont joué le jeu
comme les autres établissements de santé
en coopérant fortement avec l'ensemble
des acteurs sur leur territoire et le
poursuivre pour pouvoir justement
assurer cette continuité de prise en
charge je tenais à évoquer les chiffres
d'activité des centres puisque
l'activité en 2009 atteint est supérieur
de 13 % par rapport à 2020 de 10 % par
rapport à 2019 et en même temps comme
les autres établissements il ya des
tensions inédite aujourd'hui sur les
effectifs médicaux paramédicaux
particulièrement exacerbée d'ailleurs en
ile de france dans ce contexte
évidemment nous ségur de la santé a
suscité un espoir et il y a eu des
mesures fondamentales en matière de
ressources humaines d'investissement et
notamment aussi parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de réflexions sur ancrer
davantage la stratégie de santé sur les
territoires et donc c est évidemment
très positif mais aujourd'hui le bilan
que l'on peut en faire du point de vue
en tout cas des centres de lutte contre
le cancer c'est un bilan qui est
contrastée parce que ça a été évoqué
notamment tard marie sophie le sol
les cendres de lutte contre le cancer
sont également porteurs de missions de
services publics comme l'hôpital public
pour autant une partie des mesures
ressources humaines ségur n'ont pas été
intégralement financé pour les centres
il ya donc un reste à financer important
pour les centres de lutte contre le
cancer pour les mesures qui concernent à
la fois les médecins qui je vous
rappelle sont sans activité libérale
sans pour son activité de service public
est à la fois pour les paramédicaux et
cela pèse aujourd'hui sur la situation
financière des centres dans un contexte
général qui a été évoquée de tension
majeure sur les effectifs médicaux et
paramédicaux pour diverses raisons il
est clair qu'il est impératif de
travailler et je pense que l'ensemble
des fédérations se rejoint là dessus sur
des mesures qui permettent de créer des
parcours attractif tout au long de la
vie permettre de pouvoir adapter
l'évolution des professions aux
évolutions techniques et scientifiques
donner de la visibilité à nos
professionnels
sur le plan financier
il est clair que c'est indispensable
pour d'établissement par exemple récent
duel contre le cancer qui comme le fonds
d'innovation ont forcément besoin
d'investissement pour pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre cette politique d'innovation
notamment dans le cadre de la stratégie
des salles de cancérologie il est
indispensable pour nos établissements
d'avoir à la fois de la visibilité et de
pouvoir avoir un accompagnement qui soit
significatif
or là encore il y a une forte inquiétude
de notre part puisque effectivement
concernant les investissements dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé le soutien
aux investissements structurants les
montants sont eux sont sont pour nous
aujourd'hui insuffisant pour donner
quelques chiffres récents du contre le
cancer réalise 2,9 pour cent de
l'activité mc au est aujourd'hui
perçoivent dans les années montant que
nous qui sont à notre connaissance de
0,4 pour cent du montant de l'enveloppé
investissements structurants c'est donc
compliqué de pour des établissements
comme les nôtres de pouvoir continuer à
être innovant à faire de la recherche en
ayant un soutien soutien financier qui à
notre sens est insuffisant mais plus
globalement effectivement je rejoins les
différentes interventions qui ont été
faites ce qui est important en matière
de financement c'est effectivement une
logique pluriannuel et ça je pense que
nous sommes tous d'accord pour souligner
l'importance des protocoles pluriannuel
qui permette d'avoir de la visibilité là
encore pour nos établissements et
de pouvoir adapter comme cela a été dit
de manière sans doute beaucoup plus
proactive nos modèles de financement aux
évolutions de prise en charge et en
particulier en les adaptant aux parcours
et nous sommes très supportive de
pouvoir développer davantage de
financements portent au parcours à la
qualité la pertinence afin de favoriser
les liens ville hôpital en matière de
gouvernance je rejoins l'avis sophie sûr
le modèle de gouvernance des
établissements non lucratif alors en
particulier des sortes de lutte contre
le cancer
puisque effectivement on a quand même un
modèle qui est d'ailleurs se retrouve à
l'international en particulier en
cancérologie mais pas seulement avec un
directeur général qui est au médecin
médecin chercheur en tandem soins avec
un dg à directeur d'hôpital avec des
établissements qui sont finalement d'une
taille à la fois importante mais en même
temps humaine et ça je pense que c'est
important en matière de gouvernance et
aussi avec une longue expérience depuis
plusieurs années de délégation de
gestion
d'intéressement qui je pense m'évite de
pouvoir être être regardés bon on peut
gagner à s'inspirer
pour sur le plan des des solutions et
des actions c'est vrai que nous sommes
très supporter if également du soutien à
la recherche et à l'innovation alors
c'est vrai que les orientations qui ont
été prises suite au coccyx on sent
fondamental et il ya eu beaucoup
d'avancées mais nous pensions qu'il faut
continuer à pouvoir
donner des orientations
significative dans ce domaine la
création par exemple d'une agence de
l'innovation en santé est également un
sujet précis mais qui est l'importance
pour l'égalité d'accès à l'innovation
sur l'ensemble du territoire qui
concerne la biologie moléculaire il ya
un vrai sujet concernant le financement
de la biologie moléculaire or c'est
fondamental pour accéder au traitement
en cancéro et l'innovation doit
bénéficier à tous sur l'ensemble du
territoire en conclusion je dirais que
effectivement le segura était porteur
d'espoir pour pour l'ensemble d'entre
nous mais qu' il faut poursuivre le
soutien aux établissements bon laisser
lcc qui sont à la fois porteur
d'innovation scientifique et
organisationnel
merci
à notre merci alors vous avez évoqué des
sujets en effet avec parfois des
divergences mais aussi une convergence
notamment sur le fait de partir du
territoire et et d'organiser mais à la
main du territoire et des acteurs du
territoire et non pas de façon
descendante mais moi j'avais un peu
quelques questions est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un peu sur les
les fermetures de lits dans vos
établissements vous l'avez évoqué ce
président valletoux
même si bon les facteurs explicatifs on
les a un peu entendu tout à l'heure lors
de l'audition des soignants
est-ce que selon vous il ya un caractère
conjoncturel mais est ce que c'est un
phénomène durable et si c'est un fait
une nouvelle de rap comment on peut y
remédier par rapport à cette hémorragie
de de soignants dans l'hôpital est ce
que dans les autres fédérations on
arrive à 7 à cette hémorragie
on a vu pendant la crise et vous l'avez
dit et on l'avait vu lors qu'on a
lorsqu'on avait fait la commission
denquête qu'un an maintenant pensons pas
que la crise sanitaire avait duré aussi
longtemps d'ailleurs qui a vu en effet
cette coopération qui s'était établi les
soignants tout à l'heure nous en dit on
a vu aussi pendant la crise combien
alors il me disait c'est parce que les
administrateurs aient tenté de travail
dans c'était une plaisanterie moteur
mais mais mais c'était aussi néanmoins
de dire que en revanche ce qu'on pensait
être l'après crise même si on n'est pas
dans le pré crise on a vu revenir un peu
les mauvaises habitudes si je puis dire
au galop et les vrais bien peu évoqué
président gharbi lorsque vous ai dit
finalement à un moment on a bien
travaillé tous ensemble et lançant que
ça se délite un peu
comment on peut on peut remédier à cela
pour que justement les enseignements de
la crise souad et des enseignants enfin
d aider d soit des solutions qui perdure
et qui ont montré en effet un peu de
souplesse et donc plus d'efficacité
est-ce qu'on peut résoudre certaines
difficultés actuelles par des mesures
d'organisation ou d'aménagement du temps
de travail ça c'est un sujet et puis un
financement des établissements je
l'avais un peu évoqués on a parlé
beaucoup tout à l'heure de la t2a de ses
effets pervers maintenant établi la
volonté en effet de la pluralité ça on
en parle depuis longtemps
comment vous vous verriez un financement
qui soit plus adapté au système actuel
on nous a beaucoup évoqué aussi
l'ambulatoire que vous pratiquez aussi
bien un public privé ou dans d'autres
établissements avec la difficulté de
l'ambulatoire et donc
où ça pêche sur laval le nom de la
thouars est en effet que faire des
patients qui sont opérés en ambulatoire
par exemple s'il n'y a pas à terme des
lieux d'accueil
qui font que j'ai il reste souvent à
l'hôpital alors qu'il pourrait en sortir
et de ce fait aller j'ai d'abord en
termes de coût mais aussi en termes de
charge de charges sur les personnels sur
le ségur on l'a évoqué avec mais ça on a
souvent entendu parler des disparités
entre
entre publics entreprises et où entre
les clc c'est sûr sur les figures voilà
c'est la première question que j'avais
puis je laisserai mes collègues mes
collègues en pause et qu'il y aura un
vrai un vrai point qu'il faudra que l'on
définisse bien nous ne leur apporte
cette commission d' enquête c'est en
effet cette notion de territoire comment
on organise et c'est pratiquement une
remise à plat du système
bien mesdames messieurs je vous laisse
répondre peut-être profession le
président veut le tout
merci beaucoup je vais essayer d'être
très rapides et d'aller à l'essentiel
concernant les fermetures de lits
évidemment qu'il ya un effet
conjoncturel très forts liés aux
tensions sur les recrutements les v on
constate que dans beaucoup
d'établissements les fermetures de lits
dépasse les 6% en moyenne fermeture
dudit calculé 6% c'est déjà énorme et
mais ça peut monter dans un certain
nombre d'établissements beaucoup bien au
delà pardon et effectivement c'est
uniquement lié à des difficultés de
recrutement
liés aux tensions liées ou à la fatigue
et un absentéisme qui est quand même
plus important aujourd'hui qu'il ne
l'était avant la crise et on comprend
pourquoi
et puis il ya aussi des problématiques
plus sur le fond pour le goût de
l'attractivité des métiers
bon oui il ya un sujet qui est un sujet
réel assez est d'ailleurs le parlement a
voulu mettre le doigt sur sur cette
question en appelant à un rapport qui
propose les éléments du diagnostic c'est
des écarts de rémunération de plus en
plus important dans un système de santé
j'ai à dire dans notre système de santé
et que ses écarts de rémunération entre
les professionnels étant de plus
important et en parlant de plus en plus
important évidemment on voit derrière
dans une système de pénurie de soignants
que ça peut créer des tensions qui sont
importants je rappelle que la loi
issue de la composition waris tu as
prévu qu'un rapport soit publié
évidemment j'imagine que tous les
parlementaires aussi bien dans cette
maison que l'assemblée nationale doit
être soucieux que maintenant la loi
devienne exécutive et que ce rapporte
sortent enfin il y avait six mois pour
publier le rapport on a largement
dépassé les six mois et on attend
effectivement des informations qui
seront comme un juge de paix qui nous
permettront non je disais c'est le cas
tous les rapports
dans
tous les cas celui là il est passé au
travers des mailles du filet il est
maintenant inscrit dans la loi et c'est
vrai que ça permettrait d'avoir un juge
de paix qui est demandé par beaucoup
depuis très longtemps et qui permettrait
de mesurer ce qui est en train de
devenir notre système de santé
mot sur sur les problématiques de
financement et sans faire trop long là
aussi
il est vrai que
la pluriannualité et les majeures la
santé mériterait une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle comme la
défense qui est voilà est piloté de
cette manière là et j'ai pas besoin
d'expliquer en quoi ce serait utile pour
l'ensemble des acteurs du système de
santé le deuxième sujet qui commence à
faire consensus et une remise à plat des
modes de fonctionnement du mode de
distribution
à travers
l'organisation des enveloppes de l'ondam
système conçu dans les années 95 mais
qui a bien vieilli par rapport à ce
qu'elle doit d'être notre système de
santé demain qui comme ça a été dit par
les uns et par les autres vaut mieux
prendre en compte la prévention doit
mieux prendre en compte fictivement les
différents modes de financement et de
statuts des différents intervenants
dont tout ou toutes ces raisons on voit
que le haut-commissaire calmes on voit
plus haut conseil pour la finance
publique sociale on voit aussi que la
cour des comptes maintenant plaident
tous pour effectivement une remise à
plat
de de l'ondam
c'est un chantier important lourd mais
qui me paraît majeur pour effectivement
assurer une plus grande efficacité du
système du système de financement
mois peut-être sur les autres questions
je vais laisser les autres répondre
sur la fermeture des lits moi je ne sais
pas ce que c'est qu'un lit c'est fini la
notion de lit on est arrivé à l'activité
danse est impatient et tous les patients
qui sont présentés en 2021 dans
l'établissement ils ont été soignés tous
on a fait on a réalisé par don plus
d'activités en 2025 en 2019 03 05 %
certains pensaient qu'on avait mis le
frein à main parce qu'on est en dotation
en garantie de financement ce qui n'est
pas le cas du tout les chiffres sont là
donc pour moi il n'y a pas de nous sur
le lit et on a les mêmes tensions
d'infirmer une manque 10 % des
infirmières donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
eh bien on essaye d'être inventif
imaginatif et de travailler quelques
fois dans la difficulté et est ce qu'on
appelle j'aime pas souvent mais en mode
dégradé on est obligé mais aucun patient
qui sera présenté à n'importe où avec 1
54% des chirurgies 39% la cancérologie
aucun patient n'a été refusé aucun aucun
et les chiffres sont là sur la
coopération moi je la différence entre
le début de la crise et aujourd'hui
c'était la coopération et se fait
d'homme ou de femme à femme peu importe
d'établissement en établissement c'est à
dire que des plis ont été ont été pris
des chemins ont été trouvés et ça se
passe naturellement avec des difficultés
sur le terrain de 18 et de personnes et
pas de statut le personnes
le personne et je pèse mes mots parce
que on me rapporte ici ou là des
difficultés entre deux directeurs ou de
médecins mais ça c'est la vie et c'est à
nous de nous de gérer par contre la
coopération au niveau national c'est à
dire de nom
tutelle je la vis de plus en plus mal
parce qu'au départ quand il avait eu
besoin de nous de manière forte est
inconnu parce qu'on ne sait pas où on
allait on était sollicité matin midi et
soir et aujourd'hui c'est ce que je
disais d'amoureux vos luminaires on nous
reprend et on revient sur le schéma des
économies de bouts de chandelle vu les
20 milliards + 10 milliards du ségur
jamais été mis sur la table 30 milliards
c'est extraordinaire cette somme qui
était mis sur la table et aujourd'hui on
retourne là dedans non non je suis un
peu moins un peu contrarié parce que je
me dis qu'on ne retire pas au niveau
national les leçons de la coopération
entre nous mais sur le terrain j'ai une
30 confiance sur la qualité des acteurs
et je laisse de côté je le dis les
guerres de chapelles les histoires qui
avait fédéré quand on en parle souvent
on en a à raconter tous les matins mais
c'est pas important c'est pas important
on a soigné tous les patients qui sont
présentés en était un mode de vie sain
il je retiens ça
donne mais très rapidement et pour eux
et pour compléter
oui il ya des fermetures de lits je
voudrais dire qu'il ya également des
réductions d'activités en ehpad qui a
des réductions d'activités ans yade qui
a moins de patients qui sont peuvent
être suivis à domicile et que ça aussi
ça a un impact sur les logiques de
stylisation donc j'insiste sur le fait
que les tensions en ressources humaines
ne sont pas que dans le secteur
hospitalier et que d'une certaine
manière le secteur hospitalier va va
devoir prendre des personnes qui avaient
à une autre modalités d'accompagnement
et pour lesquels les logiques rh ne
permettent pas de donc je reste toujours
dans cette vision très
très très globale il ya eu quand même
avec la crise une bascule d'activité de
du conventionnel vers l'ambulatoire et à
votre question de savoir jusqu'où ces
durable c'est moi je pense que là c'est
durable c'est à dire que il y aura eu
effectivement
une soit une demande des personnes elles
mêmes qui veulent pas envie de rester à
l'hôpital soit effectivement des
professionnels qui se sont organisés
différents et qui ferment et qui ont vu
que ça fonctionnait
et donc on va avoir ce qu'on voulait
tous d'ailleurs depuis longtemps
beaucoup plus d'ambulatoire par rapport
à l'hospitalisation conventionnelle
juste si le mouvement est très rapide et
il est très rapide on aura un problème
d'ajustement de modèles de recettes
puisque en réalité les logiques de
tarification de recettes en hausse façon
complète et en ambulatoire c'est pas
exactement les c'est pas exactement les
mêmes donc il faudra accompagner ce il
faudra accompagner ce mouvement sur la
question des tensions en ressources
humaines alors il y aura sans doute un
mouvement de balancier moi moi je parle
peut-être de façon un peu exagéré d'une
dépression collective posco vide dans un
certain nombre d' équipe et dans un
certain nombre
d'établissements et je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs comment on traite une
dépression collective j'ai dit je ne
sais pas quel est le bon quel est le bon
le bon remède mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que je crois pas qu'ils énormément de
personnes qui passent entre des
établissements des différentes
fédérations le constat que j'ai c'est
qu'il ya un certain nombre de personnes
qui quittent qui vont soit qui
s'installe en auto-entrepreneur soit en
libéral soit qu'ils quittent
complètement la profession je veux dire
et c'est ça finalement le plus grand
risque que nous que nous avons alors oui
en même temps il ya des jeunes qui
arrivent en formation donc on devrait
être en capacité de trouver mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que moi je le dis aussi
très souvent je ne comprends pas
aujourd'hui pourquoi on n'est pas en
capacité de faire une campagne de
communication positive sur les métiers
de la santé va dire voilà cinq ans qu'on
nous avons sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision des campagnes sur la défense
et les prisons moi je suis très
intéressé par la défense et les prisons
il me semble qu'en m que étant donné les
enjeux santé on pourrait avoir une
campagne le même auteur
sur les métiers la santé est là pour le
coup tous statuts confondus c'est juste
la question de ces mots le métier n'a
chanté que je veux dire c'est beau de
travailler dans dans la santé ensuite
sur la question est ce qu'un aménagement
du temps de travail et cetera moi je
pense qu'on a un sujet important de
fonctionnement d' équipe c'est le
fonctionnement dans les équipes je pense
que les attentes actuellement de ce qui
arrive dans les jeunes qui arrivent
c'est certainement un sujet de plus de
responsabilisation plus de co
construction et donc ça interpelle sur
le fonctionnement en équipe le rôle du
management une management intermédiaire
ça interpelle sur sur des logiques de
fonctionnement
et puis sur la question du financement
pour aller vite sur la question du
financement alors oui bien sûr je suis
d'accord sur les plages de la pluri
annuel isation je suis d'accord sur la
loi de programmation en santé je pense
que au delà du forfait parcours je pense
qu'on commence à y aller faut 6 en local
et plus c'est la question la dotation
populationnelle c'est à dire en fait
c'est l'idée que l'on donne au delà en
plus de la tarification ou à côté de la
tarification à l'activité quelque chose
qui rémunère la qualité de la prestation
mais quelque chose qui rémunère
également sur le suivi d'une population
donnée sur un territoire donné en
prenant en compte les caractéristiques
de cette population
[Applaudissements]
concernant affections les tensions sur
les effectifs et les lits fermés ou les
difficultés pour pouvoir absorber
l'activité c'est sans doute ça
effectivement la réalité cela nous
concerne tous et cela effectivement on
tu trouves une problématique importante
dans les centres de lutte contre le
cancer en particulier comme je les dix
ans en ile de france
puisqu'il n'ya une pénurie notamment de
process soignants de nuit ce qui oblige
ces établissements un recours massif à
l'intérim ce qui effectivement
source de sans aucun doute non qualité
quand pour des prises en charge
spécialisée mais aussi de surcoûts très
importants
alors effectivement je pense qu'on
appelle tout ce dont on veut un plan
ambitieux sur l'évolution des fins sur
les professions paramédicales et quel
que soit leur statut c'est vrai qu'on a
on a les différentes fédérations ont
souvent enfin ont appelé de leurs voeux
une politique ambitieuse en matière
d'eau premiers sont professionnels
devaient eux mais également
effectivement un plan de communication
qui permettent effectivement de
promouvoir les métiers ça nous paraît
vraiment je pense à tous et toutes une
urgence
ensuite c'est vrai que d'arrêt important
de reconnaître et de valoriser
l'activité des professionnels qu'ils
soient paramédicaux et médicaux pour les
paramédicaux dans le cadre des
coopérations ou dans le cas des
pratiques avancées et c'est vrai que je
donnerais une illustration qui montre
parfois la complexité dans laquelle se
trouvent nos établissements en
cancérologie en hématologie en
particulier il y a aujourd'hui des
infirmiers en pratique avancée qui sont
formés vous savez que la formation est
longue et coûteuse d'ailleurs pause
établissement est aujourd'hui
l'établissement de santé contrairement
aux achats de pratiques avancées qui
sont en libéral ne peuvent tarifs et
l'activité des athéniens de pratiques
avancées il n'y a pas encore eu au
niveau national deux textes le
permettant résultats il y a la moitié
des centres de lutte contre le cancer
par exemple qui ont pu négocier avec
leurs ces femmes la possibilité de de la
tarifées et la moitié qui ne le peuvent
pas or c'est aussi une dimension
symbolique on ne peut pas demander à des
établissements de faire cet effort à des
prochaines de se former que parce qu'ils
sont établissements de santé ne puisse
pas tout simplement valoriser leurs
activités alors il va sans doute comme
ça des mesures peut-être
immédiate qui permettrait d'améliorer la
situation
concernant l'ambulatoire et vidéos
mobiles à thouaré d'achat des évidemment
le développement de la coopération ville
établissements de santé doit être
accompagné par des mécanismes de
financement ad-hoc pour vraiment créer
évidemment un effet incitatif alors on
peut citer des articles 51 c'est
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre mais quand
les professionnels de ville et les
établissements de santé parviennent à le
faire alors cela est vraiment très
intéressant c'est par exemple on peut
prendre l'exemple des chimiothérapie
orale ou des immunothérapies qui sont
faites à domicile en lien avec les
pharmaciens de ville les infirmières des
médecins libéraux et cela nous paraît
très intéressant de nature à devoir être
à être devoir être développées enfin sur
le système de financement la
pluriannualité évidemment fondamental
comme cela a été rappelé la nécessité de
transparence aussi c'est vrai que nous
avons actuellement une inquiétude
immédiate du fait de l'absence de dégel
tarifaire avant la fin de l'année qui va
pénaliser par exemple des établissements
comme les nôtres qui ont comme je l ai
souligné une activité forte et en même
temps des difficultés de financement
liées au contexte que nous avons que
nous avons évoqués donc c'est vrai que à
la fois la pluralité mais aussi je
dirais oui une transparence et une
stabilité en fait du système de
financement est fondamental pour les
établissements
merci des questions de l'eau collègue
madame de la provôté
[Musique]
oui mais merci beaucoup
revenir sur la question des coopérations
je pense que c'est vraiment le coeur du
système
l'autre ne du système étant la question
du financement et l'arbitrage entre la
sécurité sociale qui est l'accès
équitable aux soins pour tous et le
financement de la santé parce que
financer la sécurité sociale c'est pas
faire le financement de la politique de
santé et qu'il ya une confusion
dans les débats budgétaires entre les
deux et que clairement on doit décorer à
un moment ces deux questions se dire la
survie du système de la sécurité sociale
est une bonne politique de mise en
oeuvre d'une bonne politique de santé et
que
c'est vraiment un sujet mais la question
des coopérations c'est quand même a été
souligné plusieurs fois le regard un peu
différenciés et
c'est la réalité sud des tutelles selon
qu'on est fonction publique hospitalière
selon qu'on est relève du privé selon
premier théâtre selon qu'on des centres
de lutte contre le cancer et que
clairement ce regard différencier se
traduit dans s'est traduit dans le dans
le ségur enfants là on l'a vu de façon
évidente est formel
mais se traduit aussi dans les
arbitrages qui ont été faits sur le
maintien ou pas de certaines prises en
charge de certaines lignes de prise en
charge dans les cliniques privées qui
ont été supprimés pour pouvoir
privilégier l'activité hospitalière
parce que c'était le choix
d'organisation territoriale je le dis
pas comme une critique c'est factuel fin
jeudi on l'a tous vécu dans nos
territoires donc on sait que ça a été
traduit comme ça et là on se retrouve
face à une situation finalement il ya un
certain nombre de praticiens qui
retourne dans des structures où il ya
plus les lignes de soin je pense à la
chirurgie cranio par exemple des choses
comme ça qui sont très pointus très
technique mais qui clairement souhaité
privilégier en milieu hospitalier
et donc les coopérations elles sont
compliquées parce que effectivement ce
qu'il faut voir c'est le patient ou
est-ce qu'il est mieux prise en charge
pour sa pathologie dans son contexte
social et dans son contexte territorial
est le seul sujet qui vaille c'est
celui-là et on aurait pu avoir une
opportunité avec les regroupements
hospitaliers les femmes j'ai acheté en
élargissant le raisonnement j'ai acheté
or l'hôpital à la prise en charge sur un
plateau territoriale par un plateau
technique globalisé dans lequel le privé
avait sa part dans quel les centres de
lutte contre le cancer avaient leur part
et sap a été mise en place et donc je
voulais quand même vous poser cette
question là où on en est du bilan déjà
acheté où on sait bien quand même on est
arrivés un peu au bout du bout de ce
qu'on peut en faire déjà acheté on le
sait quelles propositions que dans cet
objectif de coopération et finalement
d'optimisation de la ressource médicale
et de la ressource à lithaire sur un
territoire comme comment vous verriez
d'évolution des choses voilà il faut
carrément arrêtez ce système va et
passer à autre chose et ma dernière
remarque sur le 30% administrative c'est
pas le 30% administratif c'est le 30 %
non soignants ce qui n'est pas pareil
dans les non soignant il ya les
administratifs il ya aussi les
personnels techniques à tout ça mais les
30% et qu'à une réalité il ya quand même
une réalité c'est qu'en france 30% soit
pas celle ce pourcentage dans soignant
est quand même un peu plus haute
importance que dans les hôpitaux ben
quand on compare avec la gagne pour le
coup thématique par thématique on voit
bien que sur les derniers chiffres il ya
quand même une différence entre les deux
même si c'est pas ça qui explique tout
c'est quand même une des réalités et
pour avoir vécu la ville les conditions
de l'hôpital depuis un certain nombre
d'années on peut dire de femmes cinq ans
il ya effectivement un rôle de
l'administration qui s'est transformée
aussi vers plus de contrôle et peut-être
plus de présence au sein du
fonctionnement sanitaires dans les
services et du coup peut-être vais t'en
vécu comme un élément bloquant du
fonctionnement naturel de la médecine
qui avant tout humain et de réactions et
de bonnes opportunités de prise en
charge du patient
merci est ce qu'il y à d'autres
questions auprès de nos collègues
j'avais deux ou trois mais
oui à la wii puisque personne ne pose la
question
est ce que le statut hospitalier est un
blocage pour l'évolution des soins dans
le cas de l'hôpital
et est ce que la permanence des soins
peut être acceptée paul ii dans le par
le public pour une ouverture vers le
privé
merci manger deux trois questions vous
avez évoqué le président va le tout le
peu de bureaucratie mangez pas ce
sentiment là où aujourd'hui
est ce que vous faites référence à une
une gestion
[Musique]
pyramidale est ce que vous pouvez nous
nous en dire plus
vous parlez de crise des vocations
que préconisez vous en regard
et puis madame vous avez parlé dospital
au centrisme
que préconisez vous pour en tout cas
évoluer et faire en sorte qu'ils ne ce
qu'il n'occupait pas une place aussi
importante dans le dispositif de de
santé aujourd'hui et et de gestion et de
conspiration de de nos et holly de
nouveaux établissements
je vais compléter comme ça vous pourrez
répondre globalement c'est sur le
fonctionnement en équipe et nous a
souvent été dit et papa que l'audition
précédente mais lors de l'entretien que
j'ai eu pour préparer préparer cette
commission denquête
que la notion des pôles
avait un peu cassé le fonctionnement en
équipe du service
votre avis sur ce sujet et on nous a
beaucoup évoqué aussi le temps passé par
des soignants à faire de l'administratif
quand il faut remplir les fiscs est
offert tous les systèmes de fiscalité
des de traçabilité sur lequel on a quand
même néanmoins du mal à revenir c'est
notamment sur la traçabilité
ça nous a été beaucoup d'idées un terme
on dit mais on passe parfois la moitié
de notre temps à appeler le médecin
traitant parce qu'on n'a pas un d un
dossier médical encore performant de ses
personnels encore performant on est dans
un coin de l'hôpital on se déplace à
l'autre bout va skier plus de wii fit
donc des choses qui nous apparaissent
quand même tout à fait difficile hélas
quand même c'est du temps de soins qui
n'est pas fait et qui pourrait être fait
donc je pense que c'est quand on parle
sur administration peut-être un peu la
création de structures supplémentaires
qui ont peu augmenté une charge
administrative pas forcément utile pour
le fonctionnement mais il ya quand même
un peu comment on peut pallier pallier
toutes ces difficultés qui sont
rencontrés au quotidien par les
soignants
merci excusé manger j'ai encore une
autre question si vous le permettez sur
la place du diem paix dans nos dans nos
établissements et surtout dans la
coordination au niveau des acteurs
professionnels
dans la prise en charge notamment 22 nos
patients mais aussi de la qualité de la
sécurité de la gestion des risques est
ce que ça peut être un levier est ce
qu'il est vraiment temps de le mettre en
place qu est surtout de l'utiliser
merci
juste une petite expérience
sur mon territoire on a fait la fusion
de deux hôpitaux
vous avez dit qu'en faisant la fusion
des deux hôpitaux ce serait très bien ça
ferait des économies
que tout irait mieux d'abord il ya eu un
problème entre les médecins déjà chacun
voulait rester sur son hôpital
absolument et ils n'ont pas réussi trop
bien 100 ans et même j'ai dix ans après
on sent que l'entente n'est toujours pas
là et que c'est compliqué donc juste la
question vous pensez quoi de ces fusions
de des hôpitaux surtout qu'on avait dit
qu'on ferme une maternité dans un des
deux du coup on en garde un regard de
qu'une maternité et que du coup les
personnes et récents problèmes
dans la maternité
[Musique]
voilà et enfin tout ce qui s'est fait
ces cas une fuite et de résultats de la
maternité la seule invitée sur les deux
qui restent et elle a beaucoup moins de
patients que les deux hôpitaux réunis
parce que les patientes sont partis
ailleurs voilà donc
je trouve que le résultat quand on
regarde ça je suis peu voilà je suis élu
je suis pas du tout dans le corps
médical eh bien je m'aperçus que ça n'a
pas fonctionné que l'on aurait pensé
vous regardez c'est chez moi
c'est le trio public
[Musique]
c'est le public ce que je pense et je me
sentais visé nous les fusions ça se
passe bien
je suis le président veulent tous oui
alors beaucoup de beaucoup de questions
je vais essayer dé prendre j'essaie de
les prendre dans l'ordre sur sur les
coopérations
les groupes hospitaliers territoire où
ont été faits pour
donner des stratégies des perspectives
de territoire aux établissements publics
de même que les communautés
professionnelles des territoires en
santé les cdc pts ont été faits pour les
libéraux avoir des coordinations privé
de même que mon voisin pourrait parler
des stratégies des groupes privés qui
ont organisé leur offre en part en
fonction des établissements de leur
propre société
puisqu'ils appartiennent à leurs
sociétés privées donc j'ai chaque
secteur a pu avoir des des entrées des
perspectives de stratégies territoriales
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose évidemment que dans un système
pensé sur une feuille blanche et qu'on
voudrait
je vais dire intelligent bon l'état
serait stratège c'est à dire à la fois
défi était incapable de définir
territoire par territoire quels sont les
objectifs de santé publique parce que là
il ya un problème à terme de mortalité
infantile là parce qu'on est dans
l'outre-mer il ya la surmortalité liée à
l'obésité au diabète etc et étant
capable aussi parce qu'il est stratège
et affûté sur ces sujets d'évaluer et de
dire mais finalement les meilleurs
moyens de prendre en charge c'est
effectivement un parcours qui intègre du
public du privé du du parapublic de
l'hospitalisation à domicile etc à la
rigueur on s'en fiche de qui fait quoi
le tout c'est qu'effectivement ont signé
une performance dans la réponse apportée
en matière de soins mais pour ça
effectivement il faut que une capacité à
définir des objectifs précis et d'autant
plus précis qu'on doit être capable de
ensuite de les évaluer pour vérifier
s'il a la réponse apportée et pertinents
alors celle approche par la
responsabilité un peu plus
populationnelle effectivement qui est
expérimenté par la fhf mais avec
l'ensemble des acteurs ou dans cinq
territoires aujourd'hui de france depuis
deux ans et on espère faire la
démonstration de cette expérimentation à
partir du diabète et d insuffisance
cardiaque et bien des maladies
cardiaques cardiovasculaires complice
effectivement améliorer la réponse de
soins qui sera pas la même d'un
territoire à l'autre puisque l'état des
forces et là je dire des forces médical
on va dire n'est pas la même d'un
territoire à l'autre donc la coopération
bien sûr c'est l'avenir mais pour ça il
faut avoir des acteurs et c'est pour ça
que je posais aussi d'entrée de jeu la
question des droits et des devoirs de
chaque acteur dans un système de santé
qui est financé par une c'est la
solidarité nationale et la difficulté
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est que on doit
être un pays très riche très riche très
très très riche puisque effectivement on
peut s'offrir un système de santé on est
un des rares pays comme ça s'offrir un
système de santé avec un mode de
financement qui est au départ elle même
mais qui a des acteurs condé statut
totalement différent et pour lesquels
pèsent des obligations totalement
différente voilà ça c'est premier sujet
le deuxième sujet sur la sueur
administration il faut pas confondre la
sueur a misé la bureaucratisation nous
l'assurent administrations dans les
quatre murs de l'hôpital et là sur
l'administration du système de santé ce
qui a prospéré ces dernières années
c'est sans doute parce qu'il ya l'assuré
ministration c'est un mal qui gagnent
tous les organisations et c'est pas le
maire que je suis qui va vous dire le
contraire donc mais elle a plutôt gagné
j'allais dire dans la gouvernance du
système de santé la multiplication des
agences les étages intermédiaires qu'on
a créée avec des agences régionales de
santé qui n'ont pas fait maigrir lire ou
de meilleurs proportionnelle le poids du
ministère de la santé lui même à paris
donc toutes ces couches successives qui
se sont créés et qui derrière importe
des politiques qui sont pas toujours
dans la plus grande cohérence les unes
des autres qui pendent des injonctions
vis-à-vis des établissements ou de
l'ensemble des frais professionnels qui
sont pas les plus cohérentes et les plus
fluides vis-à-vis
les unes que les autres donc tout ça
effectivement à créer un sentiment de
bureaucratisme galopant qui
effectivement fait dire à des soignants
mais aussi bien à l'hôpital interrogé un
médecin libéral si vous en auditionné il
va vous raconter ces journées où la
journée les 20 % de son temps qui passe
à remplir des fiches qu'on lui envoie
voilà donc ça effectivement mais ça
c'est la gouvernance du système c'est
pas la maladie de l'hôpital c'est une
maladie qui est celle du système voilà
époux et quant aux 30 % de non soignants
heureusement qu'il ya des techniciens
l'hôpital qui permet d'ailleurs de faire
des chaînes logistiques et quand il ya
des campagnes de vaccination à mettre en
oeuvre du jour au lendemain si on
n'avait pas les techniciens qui
justement ont permis de faire tout ça
évidemment l'hôpital ne tournerait pas
voilà qu'un autre tournerait sur sur une
jambe donc là aussi il faut il faut 20
ces chiffres là moi je les prend avec
des pincettes mais bon sur sûr
sur le fonctionnement en équipe moi je
crois profondément que notre système
souffre d'être encore beaucoup trop
uniforme uniforme centralisée et qu'on
devrait et ça a été dit par marc et
sophie de sol ça a été dit par laminé
gharbi on devrait faire confiance aux
acteurs de terrain à partir du moment où
l'état serait dans cette logique de
fixer des objectifs clairs et d'être en
capacité de les évaluer ce qui se passe
entre les deux devraient ressortir de la
responsabilité des acteurs de terrain et
si un hôpital veut se constituer en pole
qui se constitue en pole quand j'étais à
l'hôpital c'est avec la communauté
hospitalière la communauté médicale de
cet établissement si un hôpital veut
revenir à ces services qui se met en
service et je dire tant que les patients
sont soignés et que le système
fonctionne dire cliquez qu'est ce que ça
peut faire que l'hôpital de brest où est
organisée la même manière que celui de
beaucaire où d'ailleurs bon voilà donc
ça c'est quelque chose d'important sur
la question de la delà du statut est
effectivement est ce que le statut
hospitalier n'est pas un frein à et ce
qu'on peut partager les missions de
service public moi mon rêve ce serait
que finalement c'est notamment
concernant l'obligation de permanence
des soins ça soit attaché à la fonction
même de médecins et que chaque médecin
privé public soit porteur aussi d'une
obligation de permanence des soins est
effectivement lire le partage des
missions de service public
la mission de service public c'est
l'apanage de personne sauf que dans la
réalité c'est plutôt service public qui
le porte et c'est plutôt ceux qui sont
pas dans le service public ils le
revendiquent eux les moins peuplées mois
mais si effectivement on va dans un
système où les missions de service
public l'ensemble des missions de
service public pas pas celle qu'on a
envie prendre pas un truc à la découpe
on dit mais ce petit bout de mission de
service public je prends mes la
plénitude des missions de service public
peut être exercée par tous les acteurs
alors dire pourquoi pas en germant là
dessus nous on n'a jamais été on a
toujours été partant d'un grand débat
sur le sujet ce qui me vaut parfois
d'ailleurs des montre ans de syndicats
de médecins libéraux quand je dis ça
mais c'est pas facile qu'on ait un débat
sur le partage des missions de service
public nous il a aucun problème au
contraire bien au contraire donc
bon voilà rapidement ce que je voulais
oui concernant la fusion des hôpitaux
pardon vous allez faisons alors vous
avez cité cet exemple moi je pourrais en
citer un autre qui est le mien dans ma
vie où on a fusionné un hôpital et une
clinique quasiment enfin non je n'en
prends on a fusionné à l'hôpital et les
médecins d'une clinique parce que du
jour au lendemain j'avais une clinique
mais elle est partie en quelques
semaines sans prévenir parce que il y
avait des obligations qui étaient sans
doute liés à sa gestion qui faisait que
la maintenir une activité médicale à
fontainebleau l'intéressait pas beaucoup
donc à la ferme et une maternité en
quatre mois et deux ans après la ferme
et l'ensemble de son activité en deux
mois débrouillez vous et heureusement
des médecins libéraux qui travaillent
avec les knicks ont pas qu'on trouvait
que l'arrière on pousse un peu le
bouchon un peu loin il n'est pas envie
d'abandonner leur patientèle et donc ils
sont on a monté un contrat ce qui prouve
que l'hôpital est agile est capable de
faire des choses on a montré un gc as un
groupement de coopération sanitaire qui
est une
une possibilité qui nous est donnée qui
fait que aujourd'hui on a quasiment un
blog dédié dans lequel interviennent une
douzaine de chirurgiens privé
et qui sont tout à fait heureux de
fonctionner donc c'est un contraste de
points que je veux pas rentrer dans les
détails ici mais en tous les cas on a
maintenu une activité médicale porté par
des libéraux qui n'ont pas renier leur
statut au sein de l'hôpital public parce
qu'effectivement
l'actionnaire de la clinique avait
décidé que voilà pour des problèmes sans
doute de rentabilité fontainebleau
devait être rayé de la carte c'est vrai
que cette permanence des soins elle est
quand même assuré par le service public
donc moi si on parle du portage des
services publics effectivement ça va
nous emmener dans des débats qui
rejoindront sa boxe ça s'est très bien
passé et quant à la fusion d'hôpitaux on
le pratique aussi puisqu'on a fusionné
trois hôpitaux que je prends mon exemple
on pourra en prendre d'autres
fontainebleau nemours et montereau qui
font plus qu'un seul hôpital et on a un
projet médical de territoire on a
distribué les spécialités entre les
trois établissements on a convaincu les
communautés médicales un jour de travail
est là le jour de travailler dans
l'autre établissement et aujourd'hui on
a je veux dire garantie pérenniser et
conforter une offre médicale dans un
territoire dans lequel il ya plus que le
service public le sud seine-et-marne et
qui a permis aussi d'élargir les
spécialités
monsieur millions oui juste juste pas
frédéric valletoux toujours et puis mes
excuses auprès des autres mais le tgv
une n'attendra pas je vais devoir partir
après mais quand tu parles de donner
plus de liberté aux hôpitaux par rapport
au service ou au pôle faut donner plus
de liberté ou plus autonomie
ok moi aussi
plus d'autonomie
oui
[Musique]
monsieur gherbi
sur les shows de deux cliniques c'est
nous c'est très simple lorsqu'un hôpital
public est en déficit il fait appel à
son actionnaire qui est l'état et l'état
qu'on le déficit nous quand une clinique
est en déficit on fait appel à son
actionnaire et quand il ne peut pas
combler il n'a d'autre choix après
l'ultime recours que de demander une
aide d'état qui refuse et très souvent
parce que on le voit bien sur les
cellules investissement de 1 1 % des 10
minières ou 13 milliards sur
l'investissement donc l'état ne veut pas
aider les structures privées donc on
ferme ça c'est clair net et précis on
n'a pas le choix sur les coopérations
réanimation privé on avait 500 lits en
début de crise 500 pourquoi parce que
toutes les autorisations de l'animation
sur les vingt dernières années étaient
systématiquement attiré habitat public
comme heavy rain comme les scanners il
ya des dizaines dira m me aubry dans les
hôpitaux de lui pendant qu'ils ne sont
pas installés qui ne sont pas installés
et qui sont caduques ou trois ans et
nous on pleure pour avoir des appareils
lourds en trois semaines on a monté sans
service de réanimation d'ailleurs à se
poser la question après la crise de ce
qu'on va faire parce qu'il fait 1 100
personnes recensées dans personne qui
travaille dans un service de réanimation
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire j'espère ce
sera pérennisée donc la coopération elle
est biaisé parce qu'on ne peut pas
répondre avec les mêmes armes que dans
le public sur le pds s on est preneur
mais la pds est de permanence des soins
d'établissement pas à ambulatoire je ne
parle pas pour l'ambulatoire demi je
parle pour l'établissement et on ne la
refuse dans 90% des cas dont on peut pas
nous demander de prendre des astres m 2
pds us quand on allait quand on ne les
refuse je me demande depuis des années
qui est un comparatif des salaires j'ai
des notes une aide soignante à l'hôpital
public est rémunéré 13% de plus que chez
nous une infirmière lui pour ça c'est le
seul secteur en france où le public paye
mieux les agents que le privé c'est le
seul secteur
seul alors après pour être totalement
exhaustif et que et que frédéric neveu
ne me regarde pas les médecins les
médecins c'est différent les médecins
c'est différent parce qu'ils sont
libéraux et ils sont payés à l'acte mais
maintenant les médecins il faut dès
qu'on fasse le comparatif entre les
charges professionnelles les assurances
mon amber qu'il faut et le nombre de
patients qu'ils opèrent chaque année
qu'ils opèrent chaque année nous un
médecin et le père entre 1000 et 1200
malade un orthopédiste standard dans nos
établissements il fait 400 à 500
prothèse de hanche ou de genou par
simple plus bien sûr votre question on
compare la productivité de soins on
compare aussi la qualité parce que je
pense qu'elle est équivalent barré de
secteurs mais on compare tout ça et
après on mais je dirais d euros en face
et en demande ce rapport là on le
demande depuis des années parce que on
ne veut pas continuer à fonctionner sur
les fantasmes où il ya un secteur qui va
drainer l'ensemble des populations
soignantes et non seulement parce que
c'est faux et je vous dis qu'on se
demande encore comment on peut avoir des
infirmières aides-soignantes savoir
qu'on les paye moins ça veut dire que la
vie c'est à dire que la cuve était la
qualité de vie au travail est peut être
meilleur chez nous peut-être bien rythmé
le rythme est
géré par des soignants infirmiers et
infirmières n'y a pas de garde le rythme
de travail n'est pas de même aux
obligations de garde et se rassemblent
et vie de famille et puis comme dit ma
voisine effectivement je pense que si on
veut on veut créer de l'attractivité et
c'est un clin d'oeil aussi il faut que
que nos jeunes enfants garçons se
sentent aussi identifié parce qu'on ne
parle que l'infirmière
vous avez 12 13 ans c'est pas pour moi
c'est pour une infirmière moi j'ai eu un
garçon je vois là et c'est vrai que dans
la terminologie je pense que c'est
important aussi dans nos consciences
voilà on est pompier on est pompier un
bon pied c'est pourtant il ya de plus en
plus de femmes et tant mieux et tant
mieux mais en et pompiers on est un
homme on est une infirmière on est une
femme donc et c'est comme les sages
femmes voilà il ya cessé aussi
on avait tout à l'heure b représentant
qui était à nos firmes et
peut-être pour essayer de globaliser ma
réponse je vais la globaliser autour du
sujet déjà acheté de la paix et de la
question de l'hospitalisation et de
l'hospital aux centristes parce que
finalement on est sur des sujets un peu
et qui maintenant frédéric valletoux a
raison de dire que j'ai acheté a été
créée juste pour faire coopérer les
hôpitaux publics
absolument et et donc nous nous avons
jamais mais l'expression groupement
hospitalier le territoire parce qu'en
réalité ça donne l'impression que ça
couvre l'ensemble de la réponse de santé
alors qu'en fait ce sont des groupement
hospitalier public ça me semble très
bien que les hôpitaux publics
s'organisent entre mais ça a donné
l'idée que l'organisation déjà acheté
était l'alpha et l'oméga de la réponse
sur les territoires de santé et même pas
du tout et donc pour sortir de la
question de l'hospital au centrisme à
mon sens il ya tout d'abord la question
du prix de l'élaboration du projet de
territoire de santé qui n'est pas que
j'ai acheté il ne pas le projet du j'ai
acheté et dans lequel il faut
effectivement que l'on met tout le monde
jusqu'à présent il ya une catégorie dont
on n'a pas parlé c'est les usagers bon
donc là en l'occurrence dans le projet
territoire de santé la question c'est
comment on élabore avec les usagers et
avec l'ensemble des systèmes de santé
c'est-à-dire le domicile le libéral
enfin bref lançant le secteur les
priorités en fonction des besoins d'une
d'une population et donc si on repart
delà de la base et si on ne part des
besoins d'un territoire et qu'ensuite on
fait remonter avec un niveau de
spécialisation croissante en fonction
des besoins de populations on sort de
objectivement de l'hospital au centrisme
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé et pourquoi
on n'est pas content notamment de ce qui
s'est passé avec le ségur les
revalorisations etc c'est qu'on a
oubliées le domicile on a oublié la
revalorisation on y allait plus tard
mais on a oublié la revalorisation de
tous ceux qui font de l'accompagnement à
domicile
aujourd'hui on continue à se battre pour
la revalorisation de tous ceux qui font
l'accompagnement social et médico social
mais si on veut éviter que les personnes
arrivent à l'hôpital c'est à ce niveau
là qu'il faut investir si on n'investit
pas vis-à-vis de ces professionnels là
ne nous étonnons pas qu'ensuite ils se
désinvestissent et que dès que c'est un
peu compliqué il renvoie au niveau au
niveau du dessus donc je pense
honnêtement que là on a une clé en
termes de en termes de raisonnement mais
notre système hyper administrés fait que
c'est très compliqué j'ai aidé revient
sur la confiance on revient et c'est
d'envisager cette co construction au
niveau d'un territoire de d'un
territoire de santé et sur la permanence
des soins c'est que nous on n'a aucun
problème avec la permanence des soins on
est très présent sur sur la permanence
des soins mais l'anc
regardons le territoire en voyons les
forces en présence et organisant la
permanence il faut effectivement que
tout le monde soit partie prenante de
cette
de cette permanence et puis ma tête
parce qu'on n'a pas eue on vous a pas
répondu sur la question du dmp alors si
le dmp est un est un sujet compliqué il
est quand même repris actuellement avec
l'elysée de mon espace santé c'est à
dire en fait que ce soit les personnes
elles-mêmes qui s'approprient les choses
et est ce que c'est une solution sans
doute que oui enfin ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il faut investir ils sont investis
sur ce sujet là parce que effectivement
c'est quand même une clé moi c'est aussi
jour cédant les effets leviers que l'on
cherche c'est quand même des clés sur
les logiques de coopération notamment
parce que si on est en capacité de
partager des données d'éviter d'être
redondant sur des examens d'aller plus
vite sur les prises de décision
honnêtement tout le monde est gagnant et
notamment le patient
et moi j'ai un peu normal sur ce dossier
médical bon à la main du patient ok à
condition que le patient y mettre tout
parce que dira si tout n'est pas dedans
il est tronqué pardon forcément au pied
par lui je dirais oui l'ont fait par un
professionnel mais il faut qu'ils
autorisent ce qui le mène 2 1
% pourcentage honnêtement maintenant il
ya très peu de personnes qui refusent ya
très peu de oui c'est bien commencé
c'est quand même tout le monde je crois
comprend l'intérêt oui ces données soit
santé quelque part et puissent être
utilisés si besoin on va faire une
mission après la clôture d'un kg est
sûre les données de santé
un vaste programme
oui rapidement effectivement le bilan
déjà acheté des positif parce qu'il a
permis à l'hôpital public de se
structurer comme ça a été soulignée en
revanche il ya bien d'autres sujets qui
doivent continuer à progresser en
premier lieu effectivement la gradation
des soins entre centres de référence et
établissements de proximité qui en
cancérologie est un enjeu majeur pour
éviter tout simplement les pertes des
pertes au de chance et
et comment comme j'avais déjà évoqué une
des clés aussi c'est comment on fait
évoluer le système de financement pour
promouvoir la coopération entre entre
ville et établissements de santé pour
faire tout simplement aussi face aux
enjeux de démographie médicale qui sont
qui sont cruciaux
sur le l'excès de temps administratif
etc oui la crise et la numérisation des
des parcours de soins qui permettra
effectivement de gagner du temps pour
les professionnels et d'avoir des
données de qualité et fiable et c'est
vrai que je pense qu entre régions et
territoires là encore ces contrastes est
finalement la situation il ya des il ya
des régions où historiquement on a pu
développer des solutions
d'interopérabilité qui permettent
aujourd'hui aux professionnels de de ce
pouvoir échanger faciaux nan mais le
degré de maturité est variable et là
encore il faut sans doute s'inspirer des
bonnes expériences et plus que les
fusions c'est sans doute cette mise en
réseau qui permet aujourd'hui d'avoir
des parcours finalement notre passion
qui sont performants enfin enfin il a
été évoqué effectivement comment faire
confiance aux
aux acteurs et je rejoins que c'est
évidemment nageurs je voudrais citer un
exemple par exemple dans un centre de
lutte contre le cancer le 112 contre le
cancer oscar lambret à lille a mis en
place non seulement bien sûr une
politique d'intéressement classique mais
en plus de l'intéressement classique une
je dirais une surcouche d'intéressement
l'intéressement par projet qui permet à
chaque équipe médicale enfin fonction de
sa spécialité en fonction d'objectifs de
qualité qualité de prise en charge des
laits et c'est d'obtenir par l'équipe un
intéressement supplémentaire je pense
que c'est ce genre de mécanismes qui
permettent finalement de reconnaître
aussi est de valoriser les
professionnels et en tenant compte de
leur exercice quotidien
[Musique]